HAOHSIANG LIAO: In
a second culture,
you have a couple roles to play.
I'll give like five levels.
You can be a tourist and
you can be an observer.
And you can be a participant,
and you can be a contributor,
and you can be a shareholder.
And I always ask my students,
ask yourself, what kind of role
you want to play in
a second culture.
And that will also
guide you through when
you are learning how to do these
kind of things with a language.
And our goal here for Chinese 1
and Chinese 2 until Chinese 4,
we really-- we really
push our students
hard to the level at
least to be participants.
What is a tourist?
I mean, being a
tourist is totally OK.
So, for example,
when you go to China,
you see so many cars and
the air is really bad.
And so you say, as a tourist,
that the air is so bad.
An utterance like that
would not get you too far
in communications.
But if you can start
to be observer,
for example, so you observe
what are the reasons
involved and start to give
you some time and absorb them.
Then the next--
then the next level
is you can start to
participate in the discussions
so that the words
coming from your mouth,
they're much more
sophisticated-- they're
much more sophisticated, so that
the native speakers would have
the interest to speak with you.
So those are the five
roles that I always
encourage students to think
about what kind of role
you want to play in
the second culture.
And that would,
for the most part,
determine your efforts
when you-- when
you're learning a language.
It can be applied in
many, many aspects.
If today, the issue is
really about a [INAUDIBLE],
for example, the
structure's not right.
I always-- I
always-- I always ask
my students, what
if, what would you
react if a native--
if a foreigner speaks
to you with English like, "I
go to the park yesterday."
What would you react?
Think about a
sentence like this.
His beat-- his beat is
not-- it's not fluency.
And he has some
grammatical errors.
How would you react?
You can still react
without any difficulties,
because you understand.
But think about that
if you have to interact
with this person for 30 minutes.
What is your [? maximum? ?]
And that would also
become the motivation to
work on your language forms,
that's for sure.
Second thing is,
there would also--
there was-- that
will also give us
the opportunity to think
about what kind of level.
And the level
we're talking about
includes cultural competence and
language proficiency that when
you push yourself to be.
But I will state that as long
as you put in the efforts,
it's always rewarding.
It's always rewarding.
And I'm very happy to
state that our students,
they are usually--
they're usually
very good at this regard.
They usually find
a lot of resources
either on campus or the
greater Boston community,
to interact with
the-- to interact
with the speakers of Chinese.